what's going on to cbs news chief
political analyst john dickerson who
joins us from washington john let me get
out of the way and say good morning what
stood out to you
good morning tony
so many things stood out you had that
dramatic testimony from officer edwards
talking about slipping around on other
people's blood um reminding us of the
chaos and the mayhem that was unleashed
by a lie and
on the topic of that lie we saw how
we saw it for the first time people
including as people just saw with that
clip the president's daughter so close
to the president people right next to
him telling him this is a lie there is
no evidence of widespread fraud also
campaign advisors were shown in that
testimony we hadn't seen that before so
it just reaffirms we knew that the court
said this there was nothing to this we
knew all the state auditors said this
but the president was being told it told
this by his closest aides that there was
no evidence of fraud and yet unleashed
all of this mayhem the final thing is
vice president pence after the mayhem
started essentially acted as a shadow
president we didn't know this he got on
the phone and tried to get the national
guard out there he was doing what the
president would not i haven't i can't
think of a moment in presidential
history where a vice president has done
something because the president would
not do it
the committee wanted this on primetime
television they wanted to capture
america's attention
do you believe that what they saw was
enough to shift or change minds in the
court of public opinion
i think in a country right now where we
have so many moments of outrage so many
things to pay attention to it's going to
take more than just one evening to
change minds and you also have some
number of people whereas many americans
look at this and say donald trump went
too far there are a lot of americans who
think he didn't go far enough so where
public opinion ends up on this question
is um
uh is yet to be seen but the the thing
that's most vital about this is this is
not some event in the past this is about
whether the democracy can handle the
peaceful transfer of power and that's a
question of the present and it's a
question of our future so whether people
are moved or not
it's vital enough that if they care
about their democracy they should be
john on that question of the president
and the future you're right we won't
know where the public was and where they
go after seeing this but if we can take
the longer view you're a historian of
the presidency i'm struck by adam
kinzinger representative adam
kinzinger's comment that the hearing
will change history
do you think you've seen enough to say
that that's true
well history has been changed already
because this happened this is the first
attack on the capital since 1814 um
we've we're learning new historical
things like a vice president had to step
in where a president wouldn't uh and and
i think one of the key things is
understanding the central role the
president played one of the things that
was a part of the testimony is it's not
just about january 6. when the election
was decided president trump tried
everything possible to overturn the free
and fair election uh
as as testimony showed former attorney
general barr said we can't live in a
world where someone sees this power
on no basis i mean that's a fundamental
shot at the central tenet of american
democracy if you lose an election you
don't get to just say no i won and then
use power to stay in office that's
exactly what the founders created the
american government to push against so
uh it is
whether people see it in those
historical terms or not it is
nevertheless uh in those historical
terms that we saw that testimony and
that this story sits
yeah and as liz cheney said donald trump
first president in american history to
not relinquish power in the aftermath of
a free and fair election john dickerson
thank you very much thanks